alexéi navalni ha sido trasladado hoy a
la prisión de matrósskaya tishiná que se
encuentra también en la ciudad de moscú
esta mañana se despertó en la misma
comisaría donde fue trasladado el
domingo después de haber sido detenido
en el aeropuerto de sheremetyevo cuando
ha despertado se ha encontrado con que
las autoridades rusas le habían
organizado una vista judicial en la
propia comisaría alexéi navalni ha
cargado ante el tribunal contra lo que
considera una farsa de juicio y ha
asegurado que el presidente ruso
vladimir putin ha tirado el código penal
ruso a la basura sin embargo ahora ya
todas las miradas están puestas en el
próximo 2 de febrero ese será el día en
el que se decidirá si alexéi navalni
tiene que volver a prisión para afrontar
allí los dos años dos años y medio de
cárcel que le quedarían pendientes por
esa condena que estaba cumpliendo en el
régimen abierto y cuyos incumplimientos
según las autoridades rusas le pueden
hacer volver a prisión